I think people are very confusing
there's a lot of sort of confusion about
what's going on I think there's a lot of
fun granville statements this is what's
going on it's of it and then in the end
of the day I mean you hear you read and
you hear what people are saying and they
kind of know we come up with a new idea
it's pre-roll versus you know doing the
end or you know I just read something of
the day and the quote was basically this
guy saying that they're experimenting
with so whatever the video is that you
clicked on you play a little bit of that
and then in the middle you and his quote
was we give you a little bit of video
before we hit you over the head with the
ad and I guess my point is like people
don't want to get hit over the head
period and and and it's not you know
this is a lot of sort of fancy talk in
the technology world about basically
finding new ways of interrupting people
and I just don't think that necessarily
say whether things are going Janice your
question which is tricky one I mean I in
the newspaper world I see and I just did
this myself I just canceled my
subscriptions on the on the on the in
the week and I'm just getting in there
the weekend editions and I because I
read everything else online and then it
sort of the day-to-day news about
something another crane falling on a
building in New York City you kind of
don't have to bother you
well I think yeah I think that there's
advertising has kind of been split up
into in two things one is information
and one is entertainment and you know i
think the car a car example is a good
one because you know they spend on one
in advertising and they may be able to
do it smarter you know you look on you
know you if you're going to buy a car
you probably have a few brands that you
you would consider in a few brands that
you wouldn't consider and and then you
sort of start looking into the specifics
of it so there's there's the kind of the
entertainment the brand building part of
it which which makes you like a BMW or a
Saab or whatever it is they're into and
that's sort of the longer term stuff and
then you come into the thing okay what's
the mileage what's the guarantee what's
the blah blah blah I know and and the
funny thing about I've had the car
industry is that they're still insisting
on doing that on national television
they're doing these sort of price ads
you know in the most expensive media in
the world and then you go on their
websites and they're kind of kind of
crappy and you're the funny thing is
you're spending all that money on
advertising and you're still the end the
when you're about to make your decision
you're still forced to go to Jersey and
meet some guy in a bad suit who has a
funny accent who's trying to rip you off
and so all the funny ads and all of all
the other stuff is kind of out the
window because Joe you know in Jersey
who's like ripping you off with a car
he's not that Brandon you competing
people's people's time and so you know
if I have an hour over I can I can watch
you know a TV show or I can watch a film
or i can watch news or i can watch
something that an ad is done and or that
a brand is produced and i don't think
people see difference and you know you
need to be as lief compete with sat
night live
you